bon au commencement dieu s'ennuyait au
le sexe des anges à 5 minutes mais ces
gens là on sait jamais parquet le poulet
prompt à force de se tourner les pouces
il eu des ampoules aux mains ce qui lui
donna une idée que la lumière soit et la
lumière fut
en ça marche le deuxième jour dieu créa
la mer et les continents et les
incontinents le troisième jour dieu
inventa les animaux comestibles et il
vit que cela était bon et une queue de
cochon bourg madame et bois trine
fraîche pour monsieur
le quatrième jour dieu créa les plans le
matin les philodendron l'après-midi les
rhododendrons et la nuit les édredons
le cinquième et le sixième jour il créa
le reste je tout le reste soit et tout
le reste fut est le 7e jour il se repose
bon travail de dieu wayne on sait peu de
chose vous savez il ya encore mal de
choses à faire un héros de son pote
goudronnée j'ai pas brancher le
téléphone mais lieu le lundi suivant
déjà commencé à s'ennuyer
ça va dieu bof ça va comme un lundi
moi j'en ai marre les arbres les
prairies les montagnes tout ça ça
commence à me lasser
moi je suis quelqu'un de la ville
j'aimerais bien y faire une partie de
ping pong ou jouer à saute mouton mais
il faudra un partenaire avec raison à
dieu
oui je sais pas comment ni pro 20 viva
chile qui t'y attendais je crois que
j'ai une idée
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande la
plus grande attention
nous sommes sincèrement un reportage
direct sur dieu qui est en train de
faire les gestes qu'ils ont rendus
célèbres à une fête à paraître c'est le
prêt très belle scène d'éric au large
un buste puissant des genres à corte
presse agaçant d'appétit dirait digne de
respect il a une démarche dynamique
je peux vous dire maintenant que c'est
un français le voilà mesdames et
messieurs il s'appelle adam sont bien
bravo merci
adam janvier content d'être là ouais je
voudrais profiter de l'occasion pour
remercier ma famille et tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé en arriver là quoi a bien
hâte en janvier vous auriez pu mettre le
maillot jaune
ben oui c'est vrai parce que je suis pro
2 à dans son billet à dieu qu'est ce que
vous comptez faire pour votre poulain
dans la débrouille tout seul là je suis
pas ça me semble pas loin
qu'est ce que vous allez faire attention
biais attendez je voudrais dire deux
mots à dieu demain quoi as tu une fameux
à une femme bah oui comment faire bah
c'est bête si on n qui s'est passé là
tout à l'heure si j'avais su je leur ai
demandé son téléphone mon bep couture
reste là hein je vais essayer de la
reconstituer de mémoire alors ne bouge
pas je vais à mon atelier d'accord ça
devait ça
membre d'honneur du gala alors à webo là
les jeunes je voulais steen et de
tranquille dans le jardin surtout vous
restez l'âme et interdiction d'aller
boire un verre de cidre au bistrot d'à
côté alors âgées au vent debout
certaines soir damas ap al assad et
malpoli au cela dit les rides alors elle
lui avait tapé dans l'oeil droit
bravo au bistrot world attention à dans
cette affaire dit par dieu écoute parce
qu'on dit adam vas-y dont le patron est
très simple un jeu plutôt petit heures
devant la loupe ce serpent un divers
adore
qu'est ce qu'un jeune servir un petit
coup de sirène dans sa tête du canevas
sans oublier ses soucis elle seule est
là et bien vous joindre votre d'armes
alors les jeunes sa bannière travail ou
lundi dont trois proches et amis à ntoum
et on voit alors souffle là dedans
positive tu étais au bistrot bon j'y
suis allé mais se faire puisque c'est
comme ça tous les deux vous chasse bon
alors toi dont tu prends tes 39 heures
chez renault quittent achètera une
maison phénix qui tiendra debout 15 ans
et puis tu penseras des vacances en
famille à la tranche-sur-mer toi et tu
feras la boniche les lessiver le ménage
et enfantera dans la douleur a dit tout
à fait finalement
finalement dieu vous n'êtes quand
infiniment bon ben on finira en bon
c'est mon fils qui a raconté ça ça n'a
jamais été vrai